hi tom i'm elisa nice to meet you nice
to meet you i'm a little nervous about
this oh no don't be nervous i'm nervous
okay you're tom green
you're gonna tell me stuff about myself
but i don't know
right or maybe it's stuff that you
already know okay but you're just gonna
see it from a different point of view
okay okay
[Music]
if we had your time of birth that would
be so cool because then we could really
get the whole chart mm-hmm i believe it
was sometime in the middle of the night
i know that oh very edgy like early
morning type of thing i don't think was
ever written down exactly because i
asked my mom she didn't she didn't
actually you think she would remember i
mean but she was there there's a lot
going on a lot going on yeah yeah i
looked at your birth chart
and you know that you're a leo yep which
is great because i'm a leo too well
that's good okay what do you know about
being a leo well i know that whenever
people find out i'm a leo they always
react like oh you're a leo oh okay that
explains a lot really yeah and i don't
know what that means well leos get along
with everybody until they don't get
along with anyone
ultimately being a leo is about making
sure that you feel creatively inspired
by people i think that it's any sign
that's how i do compatibility at least
you can you can be compatible with
anyone as long as that person makes you
feel good that makes it a lot easier
yeah absolutely so some signs are
totally incompatible with other signs
though without really looking at a whole
chart i don't want to be like you're
going to be horrible with cancers
because then you know what if your best
friend is a cancer yeah and you get
along really well right that would be
not always 100
definitive but i would guess that you
might have a hard time with aquarius
okay
what month is that again
end of january into february
okay yeah okay i'll have to think about
think about it aquarius stay away from
aquarius
do you know that you're a scorpio moon
is it a good is it a good thing
everything's fabulous okay good leo is
the sun for you and that means that this
is the way that you engage with people
this is how you sort of like take up
space this is how you do your sun thing
and really what that looks like is
wanting to shine so it's really
important for you to be in environments
where you feel seen where you feel like
you can radiate where you can bring
positive energy now your moon is doing a
totally different thing so your moon is
your emotional inner world it's what
goes on behind the scenes and it's what
people don't know about until they meet
you
and scorpio is very intense it is a
water sign it is deeply emotional is
very private it is very reserved so it's
actually very different from your leo
sun so i would imagine that even though
people are like a typical leo and there
might be some attributes where you're
like yeah of course that's me because
you have this very intense scorpio moon
there's also a lot of like emotions and
feelings and
memories and depth to you that maybe the
leo sun on its own doesn't fully capture
wow okay that does sound like me well
that's the thing because i do have sort
of a a contrasting thing in my
personality whereas i like to get up on
stage and perform but then i also you
know in some social settings i'm a
little bit of an introvert as well
that's exactly it i'm not so this is the
first i've heard of this
you know i mean i've never heard that i
was a scorpio moon and a leo i did not
know i came at just the right time yeah
i know it's good
i would also probably guess that you
care very much about your privacy
yeah that's true because i mean a lot of
my life has lived out on
my shows and my comedy and social media
these days but
but uh but that's sort of uh not
everything of course you know so then
there's certain things where there's a
line that i i do take seriously yeah
that's interesting that you say that
yeah yeah so that's not true for
everybody no no no really yeah and
what's also cool is that this past year
there has been a lot of stuff going on
astrologically that has prompted a lot
of changes for people with leo sun and
scorpio moon and because of some major
astrology things that have been
happening this year they have been
getting activated and changed in ways
that haven't happened in 30 years so
you've been going through some
changes very true very true i uh i moved
this year i moved from my house that i
was in for almost 20 years out to the
country from the city to the country wow
that's a big change
are you enjoying it i'm loving it i'm
loving it and it's kind of uh sort of
like what you say about wanting to have
some privacy it's a quiet place with uh
you know and i'm out in the woods it's
everything's fine
i'm doing fine
yeah i mean that's that's a good you
need to have a sanctuary exactly that's
exactly what it is because you know i
spent the last decade pretty much
touring doing stand-up comedy and you're
always out and performing and up on
stage and there's a lot of energy a lot
of people
and uh then i you know now it's nice to
when i'm not doing that to go home to uh
you know the middle of the woods
well you also have i mean i would i
would say i'm just gonna go out on a
limb here you're a little bit psychic
okay
i knew you were going to say that of
course you did
perfect
i had a feeling i had a feeling you were
going to bring that up so
do you want to tell us about it
well i do i do
sometimes think that i can sort of
anticipate where things are going in my
life and in the world and i sometimes
feel like i'm able to adapt
to the world sometimes in a
maybe just a little bit ahead of the
curve with with
in comparison to some of my
friends yeah there are some people who
are very sensitive to
other like interpersonal things and then
there are other people who are very
sensitive to macro movements and that's
like a very special thing to be able to
sort of
sort of sense where culture is shifting
and what trends are coming in and where
people need to go and that's really
special and cool mm-hmm yeah yeah
yeah so that that's that's interesting
okay pretty good to know thank you so
much